how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
relating to marvel and of course
the mcu well today was supposed to be
the release of black widow in theaters
sadly due to the coronavirus it has been
pushed back to november 6th
of this year so let's just hope that it
stays november 6th and we get it this
year
but in commemoration of what this day
was supposed to be i did do a black
widow video yesterday on my comic book
channel superhero central so be sure to
go check that out to get your fix of
black widow
but today we have some news about neymar
and his
introduction to the mcu including that
avengers endgame easter egg that
everybody knew was about namor but was
never confirmed
until now and not only do we have
confirmation about the avengers in-game
easter egg but there's a rumor going
around that namor is set to appear in
not one not two
but three movies in phase four and phase
five
so i'll break down every single thing
that you need to know about these new
reports in this video but first if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
can stay up to date on everything
relating to the mcu
so if you are unaware of the avengers
end game name or easter egg let me
refresh your mind
there's a scene in avengers in-game with
black widow at the avengers compound and
she's meeting with all of the other
avengers
via hologram at this point in time black
widow is the head of the avengers as
they currently stand and she's called
the meeting to check on the well-being
of the earth and
the galaxy as well and in this meeting
there is nebula and rocket
okoye captain marvel and roadie and at
one point natasha asked akoyi
did you get a reading on those tremors
okoye then responds it was a mild
subduction
under the african plate natasha then
says do we have a visual
how are we handling it okoye then says
nat it was an earthquake
under the ocean we handle it by not
handling it now for those of you who are
not aware
wakanda and atlantis which is where
neymar is from have
a very long history together and a very
big
rivalry now when they said this in
avengers in-game a lot of people
immediately thought
atlantis the earthquake was caused by
neymar and his
people and akoyi most likely doesn't
want everybody to know about the
atlanteans
after all wakanda was kept a secret to
everybody for many many years they
probably don't want word of atlantis
getting out but this easter egg was
never confirmed until the other day
a few days ago christopher marcus and
steven mcfeely the writers for avengers
in-game took over comicbook.com's
twitter account during a quarantine
watch party
and during this time they did a q a they
took some questions from fans on twitter
in which one person asked was a koi's
message about dealing with underwater
tremors by
leaving it alone a direct reference to
atlantis and
namor in which christopher marcus
replied sometimes you plant seeds
sometimes they grow and this is
definitely a confirmation if it was not
an easter egg they would have simply
said no
they have said no to questions like
these in the past before they would have
simply said no
again instead they confirmed that they
planted a
seed and it's growing and that seed is
namor and his introduction to the mcu
now namor coming to the mcu was pretty
much inevitable as we had it
especially with black panther and the
introduction of wakanda to the mcu
not to mention the x-men are coming and
the fantastic four as well and namor has
a big connection to
both of those groups and as i mentioned
before there's a rumor going around that
namor is going to be appearing
in three films first to appear in the
eternals which we've had a report for
in the past already then appearing again
in doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness until finally debuting in black
panther 2 as the main antagonist of the
film
now like i said it's just a rumor for
now however we have had
individual reports in the past that have
said that namor is going to show up
in the eternals along with his city
atlantis and then we have also had a
report that he's going to show up
in doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness and as far as him showing up as
the villain in black panther 2 story
wise it makes the most sense but let's
talk about his first appearances
in the mcu as rumored the first report
that we got for neymor was that he is
going to be
appearing in the eternals film and
atlantis is going to be appearing as
well what it's supposed to show
is apparently the sinking of atlantis
this makes a lot of sense to show and
tease in the eternals because the
eternals are essentially
immortal beings they live for thousands
and thousands of years and
the eternal's film is going to show them
over various different points throughout
their lives
and it's already been confirmed by
various different set photos that the
eternals are going to
visit the ancient egyptian and ancient
mayan times we have leaked photos from
the set that
show the tomb of the space gods and the
report is is when the eternals are
back in that era in the film they're
going to show the seeking of atlantis
now the avengers in-game easter egg is
not the only name or easter egg that
we've had in the mcu there was actually
one in iron man 2.
in a scene in iron man 2 where tony
stark is speaking with nick fury there's
a hologram in the back with a world
map on it on the map there are several
locations that are marked one
is wakanda and at this point wakanda had
not really been mentioned the only thing
that had been mentioned was
vibranium but there's another mark that
is right next to wakanda
in the middle of the atlantic ocean and
there's only one thing that could be
right off the coast of africa in the
middle of the atlantic ocean and that
is atlantis now at the time there were
plans for a namor film
to be in development but unfortunately
due to the rights of neymar the project
was shelved the rights to namor are
pretty much the same as the rights to
the hulk
you can have him in a group team-up film
but he can't have his own solo film so
the next play is to introduce him in
another film
now rumor has it that a version of
neymar will be shown
in the eternals when atlanta sinks
however we may not get that good of a
look at him his real debut is really
going to be in black panther 2.
namor being in black panther 2 is an
extremely big deal for the future of the
mcu and here's
why the x-men could be heavily involved
wakanda and atlantis and the comics are
known for being at war with one another
this starts because neymar gets
possessed with the phoenix force
there's a battle between the avengers
and the x-men and t'challa allows the
avengers to use wakanda as their home
base
neymar possessed with the phoenix force
along with other x-men
launch an attack on wakanda namor hits
wakanda with a huge
tsunami which practically destroys the
majority of the city
wakanda quickly rebuilds and they seek
revenge on atlantis after kidnapping
some atlantean generals and refusing to
sign a peace treaty wakanda launches a
full attack on atlantis destroying most
of their city
and then much like an avengers infinity
war thanos would eventually come to
earth
seeking the infinity stones and wakanda
was one of thanos's targets
wakanda managed to win the first attack
by thanos and his black order but then
neymar
told a proxima midnight of the black
order where the infinity stone was
proxima midnight then led an attack on
wakanda and wakanda had to retreat
so as you can expect atlantis and
wakanda don't exactly get along
and although we aren't going to have an
avengers versus x-men show up in black
panther 2 the x-men should be entering
their way into the mcu at least
a little bit when black panther 2 comes
out but the real kicker that would
involve some of the x-men
namor the fantastic four and some of the
avengers as well as the
illuminati and the illuminati could
appear in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness
not too long ago mikey sutton reported
that marvel's planning on introducing
the illuminati and doctor strange too
now the illuminati is a secret group
formed by the leaders of various
different superhero groups
the avengers the fantastic four the
x-men the inhumans etc
and together as a group they all share
information and decide
secretly how all of the individual
groups of superheroes will correspond to
any earthly threat or any threat that is
universal that could affect earth
tony stark was the original organizer of
the group and he represents the avengers
he also represents
normal humans without any superhero
abilities reed richards aka mr fantastic
represents the fantastic four
and represents the science-based part of
the superhero community
black bolt the king of the inhumans
represents the inhumans of course
professor xavier represents the x-men
and is there on behalf of the mutant
community
of course doctor strange sorcerer
supreme represents for the mystic side
of the marvel universe and then there is
namor the king of atlantis who is there
to represent
the anti-hero mindset now what's
interesting is black panther was
originally asked to join but he declined
and this is something that could play a
factor in the mcu
you see marvel likes to set things up
and then give hints that something is
coming
way in advance they actually did this
with black panther and wakanda in the
very first captain america film captain
america the first avenger they
introduced vibranium not this one no no
that's just a prototype what's it made
of
vibranium is stronger than steel and a
third the weight
it's completely vibration absorbent
how come it's not a standard issue
that's the rarest metal on earth
then of course vibranium black panther
and wakanda would go on to play a major
role in the mcu
but they also did this with captain
america and the incredible hulk they
teased the super soldier serum and then
eventually they would go on in captain
america the first avenger to inject
steve rogers with that serum making him
into captain america
and now we have two easter eggs two
unspoken
easter eggs for namor the location
pinpointed in iron man 2 and then the
avengers in-game underwater earthquake
easter egg
but now it's time for the more obvious
easter egg in the first captain america
film howard stark literally said the
word vibranium and that's where the
eternals come in
if we do see the sinking of atlantis
they will most likely refer to the city
as atlantis and this will most likely be
our first
true teaser for namor then in doctor
strange and the multiverse of
madness if they do form the illuminati
this will be the first true appearance
of namor
and then if everything comes together
like the reports say namor will finally
make his actual mcu debut
in black panther 2. so namor is coming
to the mcu the writers of avengers
in-game admitted that they did put that
name or easter egg in the film
and now it's only a matter of time until
we get an official tease
so let me know what you think about this
news and let me know how pumped you are
for namor to enter the mcu be sure to
let me know what you think about this
in the comments down below again don't
forget to subscribe to stay up to date
on all things relating to the mcu and
for live updates you can follow me on
twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof